Je peux parler avec vous et interviewer avec
tu écris
nous avons payé 1200 $ pour nous avoir
amené à trois kilomètres de la frontière
de Russie oui c'est parce que si vous
vous vous tenez honnêtement oui, c'est-à-dire en partant
La Russie pourrait être retardée d'au moins 72
heure minimum on a payé tout cet argent
est sorti
toutes sortes de chemins de chèvres pour environ 2
kilomètres jusqu'au premier point de contrôle va Mes vacances
on revient comme ça
route qui s'est bien reposé ici
pour une raison quelconque, des temps à la frontière
notre président déclare la guerre aux conjugués
état sur absolument certains
motifs illégitimes en les ajoutant
une partie essaie maintenant de tricoter la population
frère guerre meurtrière absolument
Susceptible d'être déclaré militaire
statut à la suite de l'adhésion
ces territoires de l'est
l'Ukraine à la Russie et, en conséquence
plus déjà la mobilisation mondiale je suis pour
je ne me vois pas vraiment
idéologique idéologique juridique
raisons de participer
dans cette guerre